Speaker 1: Hey, why do people call me to have
me defend communism? I'm not a communist.
Why would you call me to have me defend
that? Here's a voicemail or voicemail number
is two one nine two. David P and I just don't get
Why does anyone care to have me defend communism?
I'm not a communist. This is very this guy
calls in all the time asking me to defend
things that just have nothing to do with me.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, it's Juan again. Yeah,
a very concise question. Please like
these. If communism is so great,
according to people that support communism,
Speaker 1: well,
talk to them. I'm not one of those people.
Speaker 3: Then why do they prohibit their people?
From living, from leaving the country.
The communism rings them, right.
If it's true, that is very good,
they will need to restrict people from leaving,
they would just leave it open and naturally the
people would just stay there because it's a great
system. Sure. So if it's a great system. Oh.
Why are they prohibited from leaving? Mm
hmm. You know what, I screwed up because
I wasn't reconciled, but you get where I'm
going, right? I'd like to hear that. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Ask a communist one. Don't ask
me. I don't defend communism on this show.
This is a great opportunity for me to mention.
Later this month, I am going to be in Florida
and I am going to appear on the Patrick
Bet David podcast. He's got a huge YouTube
Channel three four million subscribers.
He's got a podcast so long form podcast,
Patrick, that David is not on the left, and he
asked for a progressive to come on and explain and
defend progressivism. And I said, I'll do it. And
he said, Let's do it. We're going to have you on
now. One of the things I'm not going to do on that
show is defend stuff that I don't believe in. So,
you know, one of the difficult things about these
these types of interviews is it's very plausible
that I'll go down there and he'll go, where?
Well, how can you like it? Just this is just an
example. How can you defend the Women's March not
allowing Jewish women on their leadership because
Jewish women aren't intersectional enough? I'd
go, No, no, I don't. You got to ask someone who
who supports that. I don't. I don't support that.
This is like one silly example, but the point is
I'm not going to defend positions that are not
mine. I will tell him, You got to ask someone
who believes that, and I will say if it's
something that some kind of fringe thing.
Not very many people on the left actually believe
that, and it's sort of like saying, Well, gee,
do do we need Mitt Romney or would we have
asked the late John McCain to defend, you know,
Richard Spencer or some white nationalists? But
no, it doesn't make any sense. So how do we defend
things I believe in? I'm not a communist. I'm not
here to do apologies for communism. All right,
my friend. Thank you very much. On the bonus
show today, the Russian convoy appears stalled
because the tanks don't have much gas and a lot
of crazy things are happening. We're going to
talk about that on the bonus show. Today, the
governor of Iowa has signed a flat tax into
law. Many states actually have a flat tax,
so it's not as unusual as you might think,
but we'll talk about flat taxes more generally.
And yes, oil prices are surging as there are
reports which we will talk about tomorrow that
the Russia Ukraine war could last could last
10 to 20 years. But hopefully it won't. And
if it did, it wouldn't be like the current
situation. But we'll talk about all of that on
today's bonus show. Producer Pat will join me.
Don't miss the bonus show. Sign up at
Join Pack Mid-Con and get instant access.